let's see what's happening on the phone
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is the number bigger
unusually huge Newsweek and I'm curious
to hear what people think we'll start
with our caller from the 905 area code
caller from 905 what's on your mind hi
there my name is Dean do you hear me
yeah go ahead Dean I'm actually calling
from Canada that's okay so I have a
pretty simple question I think yeah so
in Canada with the exception of like 10%
of the population who wanted Trump like
figure I think people tend to be a lot
more progressive so as I'm sure you can
imagine Trump tends to affect us almost
as much as he affects you like not quite
but often the case so do you think
there's anything Canadians or others can
do report that progressive cause in the
US and maybe help the fight Trump you
know not really and the reason why Dean
is that the people who care about what
Canadians think are already not voting
for Trump right like the the people who
we need to convince if the goal is to
convince people are the people who when
we hear Canada is disgusted with what
Trump is doing France believes that what
Trump is doing is an embarrassment Japan
can't understand how this man is
president they say who cares what those
other countries think like but by their
the very nature of their politics they
don't care what people in other
countries think so
I think if there is one thing that
Canadians can do its work on getting
progressives to vote you're not going to
change the minds of the Trump voters but
voter turnouts really low in this
country so if you can get people who
would not vote for Trump just to go vote
for whoever it is that ultimately is the
candidate or or in the midterms as well
I think that's the only thing I can
think of on Ford I wish there was more
you could do no I understand I don't
know it can be the easiest thing all
right thank you David okay Dean
appreciate the call I love hearing from
our neighbors to the north yeah he sort
of apologized that he was calling from
Canada but I said no don't apologize
that's that's a great thing